hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we'll be looking at why Greek
sounds like Spanish what Greek sounds
like Spanish if you've never noticed it
yourself that I'm sure that idea sounds
ridiculous I mean they're both
indo-european languages and share a
common ancestor language but Greek
essentially forms its own branch of
indo-european while Spanish is a member
of the Romance language branch but many
native speakers of both languages say
that they sound alike for example some
Spanish speakers say that Greek sounds
like a Spanish speaker talking in a
made-up language without even trying to
fake a foreign accent but do they really
sound alike before we go any further
let's stop for a minute and hear a
sample of each language listen with an
open mind and see if you think they
sound alike first European Spanish
Barcelona
cincuenta we coddle accustomed liter na
se na cidade my famosa por su
architecture ah modernista so clima
suave yo gente Birte la ciudad estar de
da de poor morale st paul Montana's al
Oeste et nos redder de cuatro mil años
de historia so trashy um principal
es la sala de Familia una basilica
católica de Sanada poor Antonio Gaudi
kcn constructions into 26 años después
de línea de las horas and now modern
Greek Poli mo na Athena Athena any pro
TiVo sets alavés brisket astronomer
Atticus cave Rosetta Pato Ajo Pelagos EF
ena ena pots are hot response no Cosmo
Agios kiriona Metis Tom Barton on a pure
graffiti espero Hasty's in a plaka occo
que toman austerity club sofia tonal a
non
Ziegler Gazette st protest code at ease
y para Makris polish initia Oh Boober
una Padre on a catechism
so what do you think do they sound alike
I'm willing to bet that a lot of you
said yes so what makes them sound
similar in many ways they have similar
phonology this is particularly true when
we're comparing modern Greek to European
Spanish or Iberian Spanish similar
consonants if we ignore writing and
focus only on sounds the Spanish and
Greek constant
inventories that's just a fancy way of
saying the consonants that appear in
each language are almost exactly the
same I imagine that a lot of you are
more familiar with Spanish consonants
and Greek ones but Greek also shares
most of the consonants that you might
consider characteristically Spanish ha
here's a Spanish example Hindi and
here's a Greek example Holly yah Amar'e
oh yes ah
this represents the soft G sound in
Spanish for example silent a meaning
giant here at the second G is pronounced
as a soft G silent a and in this Greek
word meaning blue as Allah knows in
Greek this letter is always pronounced
with that soft G sound so a Spanish
example whew that meaning City and a
Greek example CMOS meaning anger the
thought sound doesn't appear in most
European languages so it may stand out
as quite a noticeable characteristic of
Spanish and Greek and make them sound
somewhat similar though it's worth
noting that this sound is mainly a
feature of Iberian Spanish European
Spanish and doesn't appear in other
dialects of Spanish yeah a Spanish
example baño meaning bathroom in
standard Greek this isn't really a
separate consonant but basically the
same sound can occur if na is followed
by certain diphthongs and it's also used
in some Greek dialects in Greek baño
also meaning rest room but wait a minute
why is that word the same in both
languages well we'll get back to that a
little later and then there are Road
excelled Rohtak sounds for our sounds
are partly similar and partly different
Spanish has 2 R sounds an alveolar tap
da da and an alveolar trill
dadada meaning stop this road account is
an alveolar tap the in Greek trills
occur occasionally in certain positions
but they're short the main sound that
occurs is the alveolar tap similar to
the Spanish one just a the sound and
between vowels it can sometimes also be
an alveolar approximant run like the R
sound at the beginning of words in
English but the most common realization
of the Greek Rohtak is as a tap as it is
in Spanish but a satyr meaning window
this is also an alveolar tap dadada
badass fader similar vowels when it
comes to the vowels of Spanish and Greek
the similarity is clear as a bell both
languages have the same set of five
vowels ah-ah ay-e-e-ah also neither
language has any phonemic distinction
between short vowels and long vowels in
Greek there are more than five symbols
to indicate these vowels because some
symbols represent identical sounds and
the vowel is represented by a digraph
but in terms of phonetics there are just
those five vowels now let's have a look
at a couple of words from each of the
short sample speeches we heard before
from the Spanish sample architecture
demo that Mista this means modernist
architecture and we can see each of the
five vowels in this phrase and no others
architectural modernista and a phrase
from the Greek sample
this means the capital city again each
of the five vowels are present and no
others
both languages contain some diphthongs
but since diphthongs are combinations of
the five basic vowels just with two of
them side by side in one syllable
many of the dipthongs are the same
Spanish has I for example I meaning
there is or there are
with its silent H this word just sounds
like the diphthong itself and Greek has
AI for example hey Zoe
meaning donkey Spanish has boy boy
meaning today and Greek has o coroico
meaning sucker
Spanish also has several difference that
begin with the sound e yeah yeah yo you
for example Q that meaning city and in
Greek there are similar diphthongs that
begin with E and are followed by a vowel
with an accent
for example if yeah meaning children and
it's Spanish there are some other
dipthongs that are not common in modern
Greek and mostly appear in loanwords
so the diphthongs are not entirely the
same syllable structure in terms of
syllable structure Spanish and Greek are
fairly similar both languages contain a
lot of open syllables meaning that the
syllables end in a vowel rather than a
consonant for example the Spanish word
camioneta meaning van and a Greek word
cat 11 meaning I understand you might
notice that these words end in vowels
which of course means that their final
syllables end in vowels but the other
syllables end in vowels to the
prominence of these open syllables gives
a certain sound and rhythm to the
languages both languages have closed
syllables as well but in both languages
only a limited number of consonants can
appear in the coda in other words the
end of a closed syllable especially at
the end of a word in both languages the
final consonant of the word if there is
a final consonant can be no or some and
in Greek that's it in Spanish a few
other sounds are possible including the
Rohtak la duh and sir but the most
common seem to be no sir and the road
excelled in Greek Kakos a cat or Niko
see and in Spanish attract cien anos
alrededor
in Spanish one of the reasons the final
s sound is common is that it indicates
the plural and since masculine nouns
commonly end in all and feminine nouns
commonly end in aa many plural words and
in us in the masculine or us in the
feminine anos Montana's there are two
similar endings in Greek not for the
plural but they indicate the nominative
case but hearing a lot of us and us at
the end of words might add to the
similar sound of the languages I they'll
force Buderus you may have noticed that
in both the Spanish speakers and Greek
speakers pronunciation the S sound is a
little different from mine especially
after all that's because in Greek and
European Spanish at least in Castilian
Spanish the S sound is retracted
pronounced a little further back on the
roof of the mouth than the English sir
so after oh it may sound like something
between su and sha anos ll force
on top of that there are noticeable
similarities between Spanish and Greek
verb conjugations let's take a look at
the present tense forms of the verbs
meaning make or do I do
ah-hoo can you do singular athis can
ease he does or she does hace can e we
do a famous can you do plural I face
Canada they do Asin can I'm sure you
would agree that there's some similarity
in these conjugations and since endings
like these appear so often they have an
effect on the overall sound of each
language stress and syllable timing in
the video why does Portuguese sound like
Russian I said that both Portuguese and
Russian are stress timed languages
meaning that stressed syllables become
longer and unstressed vowels undergo a
lot of reduction well there are also
syllable timed languages in which each
syllable is more or less the same length
and there isn't a lot of vowel reduction
Spanish is a syllable timed language and
Greek is sometimes considered a syllable
timed language but it's often left
unclassified or is thought to be
somewhere in the middle between stressed
times and syllable times it's not
heavily stressed times like Portuguese
or Russian but stressed syllables are
somewhat longer and there is some vowel
reduction that affects the quality of
the vowel but not too much if we look at
this graph here we can see that Greek
vowels vary in length somewhat more than
Spanish vowels but Greek is in the
middle between Spanish and languages
that are normally considered stress
times but the other direction at the
bottom represents the variability of
time between vowels and Greek and
Spanish are almost the same in this
regard that similarity along with the
lack of strong vowel reduction in either
language might contribute to the
perception of their similar sound and
rhythm vocabulary so we've looked at the
phonological similarities of Spanish and
Greek but what about the similarities in
vocabulary well I think this is not as
important to the way the language is
sound as phonology because a lot of the
people who think they sound alike don't
really know many words in either
language they're judging the similarity
just based on how the language is sound
but some people may also recognize some
similar words in either language Spanish
developed from Latin and Latin adopted
some vocabulary of Greek origin these
are some Spanish words that ultimately
came from Greek alongside their modern
Greek equivalent problema problem Damon
same trauma trauma Oh Emma beam atleta
athlete is aroma aroma charisma charisma
clima clima and there are also some
latin derived words in greek some of
them from italian or regional languages
of italy so to the extent that spanish
and italian sounds similar those Greek
words might sound Spanish II or at least
romance based for example porta from
Latin porta and in Spanish Puerta baño
from Italian baño and it's Spanish
baño cuisine from Venetian cuisine ax
and in Spanish cocina but shared cognate
vocabulary is certainly nothing unique
among these two languages there are lots
of words of Greek origin and lots of
words of Latin origin in all of the
indo-european languages of Europe the
presence of those cognate words doesn't
make those languages sound similar but
the sounds of those words make those
languages sound similar that includes
the open syllables and the final vowels
that includes the similar vowel sounds
and the similar consonants in other
words the phonology of the two languages
is what makes them sound similar the
question of the day after hearing the
spoken samples of Spanish and Greek
side-by-side in the video do you think
they sound similar what similarities do
you notice and for native speakers of
either language have you ever thought
that Spanish and Greek sounds similar
what do you think gave you that
impression
be sure to follow Lange focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and once
again thank you to all of my amazing
patreon supporters especially these
people right here on the screen for
their top-tier patreon pledges so many
many special thanks to them I apologize
for my strange voice today I caught a
cold last week but you made it to the
end of the video so thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]